The Marvel rumor mill never sleeps.
Anonymous sources are reporting that Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige is in talks
with a young actor who has appeared in a Christopher
Nolan film for the lead role in a ​Nova​
feature.
Some observers have a few ideas as to who
that might be.
The rumor was reported by YouTuber TVO during
a recent episode of his video series, Lords
of the Long Box.
While he didn't offer any suggestions about
the possible identity of the actor who is
supposedly up for the plum role, the folks
at Cosmic Book News took the rumor and identified
a few stars who have worked with Nolan, and
who physically fit the bill for the part of
Nova.
Among them: Harry Styles, Fionn Whitehead,
and Barry Keoghan, all of whom appeared in
Nolan's 2017 flick Dunkirk.
Also singled out as a possibility was Timothée
Chalamet, who popped up in 2014's Interstellar.
Now, this would be exciting news if it turns
out to be accurate - but frankly, we have
our doubts.
It must be pointed out that no Nova feature
has even been confirmed at this time.
Still, there are a couple of strong indications
that the character is being prepped for entry
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In case you're not familiar, the original
Nova is the heroic identity of Richard Rider,
an earthling who was imbued with the power
and knowledge of the entire Nova Corps, the
armed forces of the planet Xandar, when their
home planet is destroyed.
As Nova, Rider has super-strength, can fly
faster than light, can generate blasts of
cosmic energy, and is possessed of the "Xandarian
worldmind."
Our first clue regarding the character's impending
arrival in the MCU came during Avengers: Infinity
War, when it was revealed that Xandar had
been obliterated by Thanos.
"Thanos already has the power stone, because
he stole it last week, when he decimated Xandar."
In the comics, Rider is gifted with the collective
power of the Nova Corps by Rhomann Dey, who
was portrayed in the first Guardian film by
John C. Reilly.
That means that all of the ingredients for
the creation of Nova are already present in
the MCU, which simplifies his eventual introduction
to the franchise.
"He's got a codename!"
"Come on, man, it's an outlaw name."
"Relax pal, it's cool to have a code name."
Our second hint comes from none other than
Feige himself, who has teased his interest
in Nova on multiple occasions.
As far back as April 2018, Feige told ComicBook.com:
"If we have a big board with a bunch of characters
that have more immediate potential, Nova is
on that board.
Because of the connection to the Guardians
universe, because there are more than one
examples to pull from in the comics that are
interesting."
Feige also noted that the character was present
in the earliest drafts of Guardians of the
Galaxy.
All of these things considered, it sure seems
like Nova's entry into the MCU is inevitable.
However, there's ample reason to view this
rumor with a healthy amount of skepticism.
The biggest problem to Nova's introduction
is that we already know every film and TV
series Marvel will be producing through 2021,
and Nova is not among them.
For that matter, neither is Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 3, which is thought to be coming
in Phase 5 and which should drop sometime
in 2022 or 2023.
If Nova doesn't get his own solo feature right
off the bat, it's reasonable to think that
he may pop up in that film.
Phase 5, however, is still pretty far down
the road - and it's not likely that Feige
and Marvel would be seeking to cast the part
of Nova at this early date.
A potential Nova solo film wouldn't even begin
production for at least a couple years, and
Guardians 3 writer/director James Gunn will
be finishing up his work on The Suicide Squad
before returning to Marvel.
With any good fortune, we'll get some hard
news regarding Nova's future involvement in
the MCU sooner rather than later.
We'll keep our eye out for any developments,
and keep you informed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.